go we're going to start from simplest to
most complex okay so the first apology
it's not quite what you expect it to
stand for in stands for point to point
point to point okay so it's the simplest
Clannad apology because you can only
have it as the name implies when there
are two points two nodes so here's my
description there's one note and there's
the other one
okay point-to-point symbol now if you
remember that transmitting and receiving
on this connection here could be a
variety of different kinds it could be
simplex only going in a mmm single
direction it could be full duplex which
means it can go both at the same time or
what was the other one half duplex which
means yeah good so send but not receive
at the same time okay and from the other
side as well so that's point-to-point
simple okay benefits and drawbacks well
the first one is it's simple as you will
discover very quickly right and use we
sort of alluded to it in that video we
watched with the end the 3d animations
that kind of thing we tend to think oh
yeah I request data I asked for a
webpage or a video or a song to be
loaded on my computer and then the next
few seconds I get it and it's perfect
right but actually our networks are and
the traffic that goes along them are
much more like real networks that we
think about real traffic right there's
collisions and problems and things that
don't get to where they're meant to all
the time okay so simplicity is a big
good thing for a network okay
drawback obviously only supports two
nodes
now like I mentioned before there's more
than this but that's just to start you
off okay let's get going the most
natural next place to go is well what if
I have more than one note okay so the
next one is called a bus a bus okay so I
want more than sorry not more than one
node more than two nodes okay so one two
three what is a bus here is a definition
for you okay it's a common medium that
all the rest of the nodes can sort of
connect to okay so like this one two
three okay let me say that again it's a
common medium that's the strip along
here is which all of them can separately
connect to okay that's vitally important
I'll put it as another color it's
vitally important that you do not draw
your diagram like this this is my bus
because can you see think about the
definition this is the common medium
here there's two media and they're
completely separate they're not common
to all of the devices okay so don't draw
this that is my bus okay this is a bus
now that medium it might be just a wire
a cable okay or it might be a space in
the terms of a wireless network but a
key is that everything goes in one spot
all right so what's a quick advantage of
that you can often think about advantage
of the disadvantages in terms of the
other ones and how are there different
okay so example get our mother to note
okay what's a disadvantage hmm this is a
common medium right it's a space that
all the nodes can access all of the all
of the nodes can send data along okay
so what would be some problems hmm okay
let me illustrate this all right I want
you to in a second turn to the person
next to you and just tell them how you
got to school this morning okay
simple simple okay ready just go
okay good that was enough unless unless
you were coming really far this way then
that was probably I hope enough
information enough time to get into fish
okay let's try this again this time I
want you not to turn to the person next
to you but find a person look around
someone who's sort of further away like
maybe on the opposite side of the room
make eye contact I want you to make eye
contact so you know who you're talking
to you ready have you got someone that's
someone do you like some cheesy there
with your eyebrows so you know who
you're talking to you and I want you to
tell them exactly the same thing are you
ready set go
oh hi shadow how did you get this
okay all right that's very okay okay now
let's come back together did you
experience any difficulty hearing what
the other person was saying maybe you
were maybe you're a bit sly and you're
like I used I used um charades to
communicate because I'm sneaky right
what's going on we were all using a bus
a common medium that we all had access
to to transmit data okay but of course
the problem was all the data was in
there at the same time right
we call this and you know when when you
can't hear someone else because someone
else is speaking to you we call it a
data collision okay because the data is
literally physically colliding right
like in our case the sound waves or
vibrations in the air they're litter and
they just all interacting with each
other sometimes you can't hear anything
I think so if you've got a common medium
you're going to have so this should
really be over here you're going to have
the article engines okay all right now I
that's not the only way there are people
who thought that this this situation
this sucks it's it's very um what's the
word I'm looking for limited I suppose
because you can imagine three notes
maybe it'll be okay right 20 nerds
you've got some problems
how about 2000 nerds okay which is not
that unreasonable for a school of any
large size let alone an organization
which is global okay so how can we solve
this problem well here's a solution the
ring topology they ring as the name
suggests we're increasing size here
right so let's go
here's a ring right so okay so here is a
ring right what happens is when confuse
want to communicate with each other okay
suppose this guy at the top once
communicate with this guy down the
bottom you will notice he has no access
to any bus any common medium that links
the two of them okay what he does have
access to is nodes that eventually
connect up to the one he wants so here's
what he does he starts a message and he
puts it in something called a token okay
now in reality these tokens are a bit
like a bit like and not to be confusing
but they're a bit like buses right sorry
I just it is right maybe I should say
trains but anyway the door rather than
around it at you trains is better
because it is teen right they got ran
around in a circle right and they keep
on going whether there are passengers
around or not right but if you're a
passenger or a piece of data that wants
to go along to somewhere else you hop on
the train the token okay and what
happens is you get passed from node to
node from station to station until you
arrive at your destination
okay the data knows when it's been put
into the token it knows where it's
supposed to get off okay another way of
thinking about it is each node knows to
listen out for things which I address to
it right so the token comes along and it
the computer will loop it up look at it
and say okay this is dressed to me I'll
open it rather than passing it along to
the next guy okay so this is a ring
network now again I said you can
consider advantages and disadvantages in
contrast to the other systems right
there sorry the other topologies so what
do you think the key advantage here
yeah not just less data collisions no
data collisions no data collisions at
least if the network is working as
intended
you see that's the difference between
the bus of the Ring if the bus is
working perfectly you're still going to
get data collisions right but if the
Rees wearing perfectly this should have
been it okay so that's that's great
that's not it's a big plus okay but that
advantage comes at a cost
what kind of cost can you think of yeah
it's way slower
well slower question mark right because
it sort of depends number one on how big
your network is right
I've just got five Birds here but if I
had five hundred it would take a while
right so number one how big your network
is number two who you want to send your
message to okay so on the bus whoever
you're sending to write your message
will arrive in more or less the same
time but in the ring if you're very far
away around right or if you happen in
next to but on the wrong side of someone
it's going to go all the way around the
ring to get there now by the way to
solve that particular problem some
network engineers have design what's
called a double ring network so like but
not to be confused with the double river
a double ring means you've got two rings
but what's the difference they go in
opposite directions okay because that
way right if you're this guy you're not
stuck are waiting to get your message
from this guy let's go all the way
around okay you can actually go directly
so the worst position you can be here is
not on the wrong side of someone but on
the opposite side okay so if we're is a
network of 500 computers it's tough to
travel through 250 one-way or 250 the
other way makes sense okay
so slower question mark any other
problems you can think of jack
ah okay so let's think about this I'm
going to give this a name and then I
want you to try and understand why this
is the name I'll give you the problem
it's called no redundancy what does that
mean we've talked about redundancy
before what is redundancy mean
redundancy your mom comes home or your
dad comes home and he's like oh man I
just got made redundant at work but they
paid me out you know what does that mean
what's he talking about
not needed yeah that's right unnecessary
redundant means unnecessary okay like
saying ATM machine saying the machine is
redundant don't need to do it right so
redundancy in an information system far
from being a bad thing tends to be a
good thing right because that means that
if something breaks down it's okay I've
got a spare right so redundant is a bit
like saying expect you go to spare time
you've got a redundant I it's just
sitting there doing nothing until you
need it so Jack was saying
Jack's suggestion was if one of these
computers get bust gets busted like say
this one okay and I just have my single
ring going around okay what happens to
the tokens as they travel well they go
to this one and every single one will
fail right so one break down means the
whole network is gone
okay if you've got a double ring what
would happen well you'd still have
problems right things might be slowed up
okay because they have to go the long
way around rather than the shortest way
okay
so though redundancy now there's one big
one that we're missing it's more of a
social and ethical issue I suppose but I
want to I want to mention it now before
we leave off any yeah that's right
in fact I'm intercepted interception
also almost implies intentionality or
skill like in touch with ball if you
want to intercept another player's pass
you've got to be you've got to be in the
right place that right eye you gotta
know what you're doing you got to be
quick right but in the ring system
um no skill is required to make an
intercept right you just have to sit
there and do your job it'll be a dream
for me right it would be like standing
there
the other team just passes you the ball
so thanks okay off I go down what's
going on remember I said okay this token
which has your data on it passes through
every single node between you and your
destination
okay so there's major problems in terms
of the safety of your data the security
of the data right so that means you've
got to encrypt things or you've got to
assume that everyone on the network is
not going to you know misuse your data
okay so that's a security issue okay now